tu évoques plus de 50000 réfugiés
Ukrainiens 50000 personnes donc qui ont
fui leur pays en moins de 48 heures
bonjour Johanna Sitruk bonjour Julien on
sait que les troupes russes se
rapprochent petit à petit de la capitale
de Kiev mais d'où viennent-elles
qu'elles sont leurs zones d'offensive en
fait il y a actuellement 3 grandes zones
d'offensives trois régions par
lesquelles les militaires russes
arrivent peuvent arriver en Ukraine on
va voir une une première carte pour
comprendre un petit peu tout ça alors la
première zone d'offensive elle se trouve
vous le voyez au nord de l'Ukraine à la
frontière avec la Biélorussie est-ce qui
est plutôt logique car la Biélorussie on
le sait est en alliée de la Russie ça a
été annoncé hier il y a notamment la
centrale de Tchernobyl vous le voyez au
nord du pays qui a été prise par des
militaires russes la deuxième zone
d'offensive elle se trouve à l'est de
l'Ukraine au niveau de la région du
gambas là encore il y a rien de
particulièrement prenons parce que c'est
une région où il y a énormément de
séparatistes prorus Vladimir Poutine a
d'ailleurs reconnu l'indépendance des
villes de lougans de louansk et de
Donetsk et puis la troisième zone de
conflit elle se trouve au sud de
l'Ukraine c'est la péninsule de Crimée
justement qui est qui est en question
puisque cette zone a été annexée on s'en
souvient en 2014 par la Russie donc là
aussi c'est un canal que que l'armée
russe peut utiliser assez facilement
pour investir pour envahir l'Ukraine
petit à petit effectivement de la
capitale par ces différents canaux par
ces différents front qu'on a vu on va
regarder un petit peu plus en détail une
image de une carte de la capitale donc
actuellement les troupes russes elles
arrivent par trois fronts elles arrivent
par le nord par le nord-est et par l'est
des échanges de tirs ont notamment été
entendus dans le quartier de Bologne qui
se trouve on le voit ici qui est au nord
de capitale au nord du du centre ville
de Kiev d'après certains journalistes
qui sont sur place des militaires russes
serait d'ailleurs déjà infiltré au cœur
de Kev mais ça c'est encore évidemment à
prendre avec précaution comme
information et la sécurité a été
évidemment renforcé dans le quartier où
se trouve tous les bâtiments
gouvernementaux c'est et si à ce
niveau-là au niveau de la mairie de Kiev
c'est là où il y a également le
Parlement merci beaucoup Johanna ce truc
pour ce point avec des